et toi alors pardon si tu pouvais aller
n'importe où dans le monde où est-ce que
tu dirais je vais faire partie des
quelque chose d'exceptionnel
[Applaudissements]
j'adore cette réponse quelque chose qui
reste qui a vraiment du sens quelque
chose de plus important que la vie
les étoiles
et toi
[Applaudissements]
si j'étais riche moi je dépenserai tout
mon argent dans des trucs marrants pas
des trucs en merdant comme les impôts
tout ce que je voudrais c'est que tout
le monde fasse la fête
[Applaudissements]
quand je suis arrivé à Los Angeles il y
avait marqué sur toutes les portes
interdit aux acteurs et aux chiens j'ai
changé la donne
êtes-vous prêts pour quelque chose de
nouveau waouh
[Applaudissements]
vous savez ce qu'on doit faire on doit
casser les codes couché nos rêves sur la
pellicule pour qu'ils entrent dans
l'histoire qu'on puisse regarder l'écran
et se dire Eurêka je suis plus tout seul
[Applaudissements]
je suis dans la merde mamie
il faut qu'on parte tout de suite
[Musique]
vous pensiez indispensables à cette
ville elle se passera de vous
[Musique]
c'est l'endroit le plus magique du monde
[Applaudissements]
qui veut me voir affronter un serpent à
sonnette
[Musique]
[__] ouais
[Applaudissements]